Você sabia que aquele produto de limpeza
que você usa todo dia pode ser uma bomba
tóxica? Olha só o que aconteceu com
jovem que foi limpar o banheiro. Pois é,
usou o cloro com água quente do chuveiro
e acabou morrendo. Veja bem, quando o
cloro entra em contato com água quente,
libera gases tóxicos podem causar desde
irritação até parada cardíaca
respiratória. É como criar uma arma
química dentro de casa sem saber. E não
é só o caso agudo que preocupa. Quem usa
cloro toda semana tem muito mais chance
de desenvolver problemas pulmonares ao
longo dos anos. Estudos mostram que a
exposição repetida, mesmo em pequenas
quantidades, aumenta o risco de doenças,
como o DPOC. É aquela coisa, você acha
que está limpando a casa, mas está
envenenando seus pulmões aos pouquinhos.
Da próxima vez que você for limpar o
banheiro, abra bem as janelas, nunca
misture produtos e se puder, troque por
alternativas naturais. Sua saúde
agradece.